so Leute was jetzt kommt ist
wahrscheinlich das peinlichste Video was
ich jemals hochgeladen habe keine Ahnung
wie ich wie das passieren konnte aber
seht euch einfach selbst
an servus Kills und herzlich willkommen
zu einer neuen Folge Minecraft heute
spielen wir zum ersten Mal auf meinem
Channel
jumplege mal raus ich bugge ich bugge
nein nein so geile erste Kiste bitte
nicht nee warte ich bin wieder oben ich
bin wieder oben ja sehr gut ich bin die
ganze Zeit aus der Welt rausfallen ja
super jetzt der Spielmodus funktioniert
so für alle die den nicht kennen man hat
am Anfang so ein Jump run der dauert i
sitzt da recht
8 Minuten oder wie oh wie
knapp oh you canot open chest als ob die
auch diesekrankheit haben
mitordord meine ich auch nichtor macht
hier so gar keinen Sinn ne weil bei H
ist es ja noch so dass man im Kampf
nicht aus Versehen beim blockhitten oder
so ja aber hier in dem Part kämpft man
gar nicht was ich sagen wollte Leute man
hat ja erst a Minuten Jump run dabei
gibt's immer auf dem auf dem Jump run
Track sozusagen auf dem Trail verteilt
diese Ender chests in diesen Ender chest
ist ja wer Frage sind englische W leicht
für dich oder schwer ich bin super geil
in Englisch Daumen nach oben wenn ich
geil in Englisch bin in dies Ender chest
ist eben Equipment drin das Equipment
sammelt man und am Ende wird man in eine
Arena teleportiert quick survival Games
ähnlich und kämpft dann als ob gegen
alle anderen undver bei auch dieser
Spielmodus kann leider Krebs verursachen
we die schon mal vor waren für alle die
gerade irgendwie potenziell gefährdet
sind ist sehr sehr kritisch hier z.B
solche Stellen Mann da muss man ja so
perfekt erwischen hast du auch am Anfang
diesen blöden
melonenkurs der der ist bei allen gleich
anfangs aber der geht der für mich Alter
als ob diese eine Stelle hier ist okay
jetzt habe ich geschafft jetzt am Anfang
habe ich einfach so gebugt ich bin
erstmal 10 Sekunden aus der Map
rausgefallen ja ja und dann habe ich
nurch gechillt einfach
ja ich für kack als ach hier oh bitte
leute danke oh nein was ist das ich will
ja nicht
verkacken ganze so ein nervenkit alter
das Schlimmste ist wenn du so eine
Blockade hast ne in dem Spiel ja ja man
muss sich halt immer konzentrieren mein
Fehler also mein Problem ist dabei ich
habe keine Fehler perfect nein mein
Problem dabei ist dass man sich gerne
mal irgendwie da reinsteiger und dann
sagt oh so eine Scheiße und scheiß Map
und dann konzentriert man sich nicht
mehr und dann macht man noch mehr Fehler
und das ist dann so ein ein Teufelskreis
da Schock sich dann gegenseitig hoch und
am Ende ist man einfach nur schlecht du
den Namen von unserem Mitspieler wie
heit der der führt gerade mis HD
Gaming kurz mal abonnieren hat
youtubeer nameft jeden Fall soweit bei
uns was h was chillig was nicht chillig
ist aber stressig ist dieser Soul
Sand was da los ist ich habe ich habe
die paran runterzufallen die ganze Zeit
m weil einfach überhaupt kein Checkpoint
ist das ist richtig gemein bei mir war
es vorhin so mein Checkpoint wurde
einfach nicht anerkannt ich wurde einen
weiter zurück nein Leute als ob was ist
das für eine Kacke dieser Checkpoint ist
so asozial gesetzt gar nicht gesetzt ist
doch kein Checkpoint hier und ich habe
volles no Equipment oh Gott der Sprung
war noch gedreht gerade gerade noch so
das ist es so alter irgendwie
normalerweise bin ich bei Jump run
bisschen gechillt aber gerade Fieber ich
richtig mit ja so wie früher bei Mario
Kart immer so in die als wir früher auf
dem Game Mario Kart gespielt haben haben
uns immer so so mitgel ja m ich habe das
letztens in der aufnah auch wieder
gemacht bei Ding bei
3 habe ich geleht und so hammer geil und
gerade eben ist auch ist auch richtig
richtig filmig bei mir
Film an dieser Stelle dürf ihr
wahrscheinlich bemerkt haben dass ich
dumm wie scheiße bin und einfach die
ganze Zeit im Kreis laufe also ich schau
mir gerade und denke was aber gibt's
euch einfach das war so behindert war
immer so lustig Alter wir saßen da
Alter es gibt do die Videos von diesen
Hunden oder so die alle so im im Takt
mitwippen die Stelle ja die gibt gibt
schreib schreib die Kommentare ob diese
Videos gibt
Leute S N bei mir und
auch diese eine Stelle ist so brutal
hier das Gute ist wir sind aber die
machen sich ja ja gut wir sind nur mit
Lappen irgendwie in Runde weil wir
gerade führen und voll am abkacken sind
ja oh mann aber die machen sich auch
wirklich Gedanken wie kann ich den
Leuten das Leben schwer machen wie muss
ich die Map bauen damit möglich großer
Anteil der der Spieler auch tatsächlich
Krebs kriegt dabei haben mit Rocket das
mög viele Mäuse und sowas kaputt gehen
ne die haben Deal mit cancer Unternehmen
wie heißt das cancerunternehmen
das das wä so Überbegriff aber das ist
die Pro cancer
Foundation politisch nicht korrekt
egal und wie soll man hier rüber kommmen
Leute wie soll man hier rüber kommmen
und wie soll man wenn man hier nicht
rüberkt kein Krebs bekommen das ist so
schwierig ja oh mein Gott ich habe es
geschafft oh mein Gott das war perfekt
K wieder so ein Scheiß Sprung als ob
Leute diese Stelle macht mich so fertig
was ist das denn oh man das die macht
mich so fertig hier es ist schon schwer
genug dahinzukommen aber ich glaub das
ist echt mit Abstand mit Abstand die
schwierigste Passage die ich jemals in
super Jump gesehen habe und ich habe
schon super super jump super
Jump ich ger umannt kann irgendeiner was
dagegen machen nein es ist mein Server
ja also chillig und geil was h von junge
chillig was
gehtlerweile komm ich f es nicht ich
muss mich da besser konzentrieren
aberimmer wenn man vor einem Sprung so
parano hat ja habe ich gerade Alter ist
so ein mögicher Sprung oder so richtig
schwieriger wo du wirklich perfekt
abspringen musst unmöglich
vespielt okay okay Max du kommst jetzt
auch erstmal runter von deem Tripp ich
bin müde Alter ich bin Schüler oh Leute
es ist nicht zu fassen das ohne Witz ey
ochch Mann ich muss mir echt in die
Selbsthilfegruppe für psychisch super
fürum
super ich bin
Flugzeug oder eine
Maschinengewehr Maschinengewehr ja genau
vier Tage kein Youtube gemacht und
direkt die Sprachfehler im
Business retorik kurz Youtube Rhetorik
ja genau youtube ist voll in Rhetorik da
muss muss man gute Argumente
bringen also ich mich wir echt echt mal
interessieren was was
gesundheitsschädlicher ist zwei
Schachteln kippen am Tag oder Jump
League spielen oh man nicht zu chill
Leute ich habe schon wieder mich nicht
konzenter was nicht zu chillen fen ja ja
Alter ich habe heute in meiner Aufnahme
ne habe ich mein den Parcours 2 Minuten
vor Ende fertig gemacht und jetzt gerade
ist noch eine Minute und ich sehe es
Ende nicht mehr und ich ich komme
einfach überhaupt nicht voran diese
diese Pass wie hast du diese blöde
lavassage geschafft die ist so schwierig
mit diesen zwei richtig schwierigen
Jumps da oh ich habe ein alternativen
Weg gefunden gerade oh ich bin
alternativ yeah GLB nicht D alternativen
Weg geht ich glaube du bist ein die
ganze Zeit falsch
gesprungen nein nein ich habe irgendwie
diese dieser Sprung der ist so schwierig
und Mann dass ich so eine Blockade jetzt
hier in der Aufnahme ist bisschen
ärgerlich Leute aber wie gesagt kann
Kutten kannst ja Kutten was kannst ja
kuten nein h sind Hal kann ich
nicht ja wie wie cattet man welche
Programme benutzt du zum cutten
Testversion von mir ich benutze
tasteron chill was geht ab e aber ich
habe echt gemerkt Leute jetzt noch kurz
bisschen irgendwas sinnvolles in diese
Aufnahme rüberzubringen ich habe echt
gemerkt dass vier Tage mal weg von
diesem Youtube Zirkus ein auch wirklich
wirklich gut tun Zirkus magst du YouTube
nicht Maximus wie geil man hat mir
einfach Rüstung geschenkt ja klar kriegt
aber jeder oder wie geil man hat mir
einach Rüstung geschenkt weil eine gute
Waffe hatte ich
schonce was hast du für eine Waffe Dings
oder Schafe
die oder ich SPI nicht viel
sorryvival heiß
man vert so schnell Hunger man aber
jetzt K ich euch das
mal leute guckt einfach an hier das ist
das ist quickäig wir laufen jetzt hier
aufinander zu und survival of the
fittest ich bin ich bin der mit der viel
besseren Ausrüstung Alter oh Weg Alter
was hat das bin ich ja ich weiß lassen
wir uns fre brauch enchantment table
oder ne hab kein Level leider was hast
du für ein Schwert steinschwert habe ich
geil hinter
dir warte ich hole ich hole nein meiner
meiner meiner meiner meiner ich hab noch
Rüstung für dich wenn du willst wenn mir
da für ein bisschen Brot gibst oder so
wirf die
Weg e was soll ich mit der Rüstung ich w
wegeben daneben noch mal kann ich mir
sprinten als ob ey wie viel der
gefressen hat ich habe einfach eine
Sekunde später abgestt ja kann man
nichts machen im Leben tut mir leid kann
man nicht gar nicht bitte wir sind
gegeneinander jetzt beide nur noch wir
beide okay dann lass fighten jetzt oneev
one Mann gegen Mann komm Rewe re sich
tatsächlich auf crazy wie einfach so ein
krassip Vorteil hat
übermäig mal soll mal zeigen ich war
mach mit dir oh m da rein chill ich hab
kein mehr hab kein food mehr free gift
so gut fre Gift unbreakable nice
wunderbar jetzt h jetzt hast jetzt hast
du aber leider Regen ja
als ob er noch feine Bogen hat scheiß
Feuerzeug m ich krieg nie ein Feuerzeug
in Jump hallo es ist
unfair un du bist selbst unf du h gesagt
ist unf du bist als ob er so viel
einstecken kann einstecken kann
einstecken kann gib mal de Bogen ich
habe keine Pfeile gib den Bogen jetzt
als ob
er ja das war schon ja
easy Alter
drecks so Leute wenn es euch gefallen
hat könnt ihr gerne Daumen nach oben da
lassen ich weiß nicht mit wem ich heute
zusammeneng gespielt habe leider sonst
würde ich euch in die Beschreibung
packen auf jeden
Fall harded schreibt in die Kommentare
schreibt auf jeden Fall mal eure
persönlichen Erfahrung mit jumpleakue in
die Kommentare und ob ihr auch findet
dass Jump Leak kanzerogen ist also dass
es Krebs verursacht dann würde ich doch
sehr gerne noch einen kleinen schnob aus
dem kopfhörerk machen wir sehen uns im
nächsten Video wieder haut rein macht's
gut und V nein